Okay.
Well,
in retrospect,
looking back from the
perspective of the 21st century,
the reign of Elizabeth the first tends
to Shimmer in the historical imagination.
Uh,
she reigned for 45 years.
She restored political stability.
She settled the religious question,
at least for the time being.
She survived a powerful foreign enemy,
Spain.
And she presided in all of her iconic
splendor over a brilliant court and a
flowering of English literature.
And at the end of her
last parliament in 1,601,
the 68 year old queen
made her golden speech,
as it's called.
She told the members of the House of
Commons assembled before her that they may
have had mightier monarchs,
but they'd had nun who had shown
greater care to defend them from peril,
dishonor,
tyranny,
and oppression.
And she expressed her confidence that
though God hath raised me high yet this,
I count the glory of my crown,
that I have reigned with your love.
And she invited each member of parliament
to come forward and kiss her hand
before they departed into their countries.
And so each member filed forward to
kiss the queen's hand before leaving her
probably knowing that they
would never see her again.
Well,
this is marvelous stuff
and she was great at it.
It's the theater of Majesty.
Generations of historians feel the urge
to bow their knees and kiss her hand
too.
And me too,
I confess it.
Um,
when the present Queen Elizabeth came
to the throne and I was a little boy at
primary school and our teacher,
Ms Cranston,
the lady who taught me to write,
uh,
told us all the stories about Elizabeth
the first and said that we should grow
up to be the new Elizabeth six,
which was a terrible psychological
burden to place on small children.
Okay.
That's how we tend to look
back on Elizabeth's reign.
But what we have to remember,
of course as historians and,
and it's hard to remember,
is that none of this was known in advance.
It's easy to forget the extent to which
her reign was fraught with crises and
danger,
especially in its early decades.
The role of her servants
in in some mounting those
dangers and the subtle shifts
which are long reign brought about in
government and in political culture and
the sheer exhausting
struggle of so much of it.
And these are some of the things
that I want to talk about today.
When Elizabeth came to the
throne on the 17th of November,
1558,
it was another sign of people's continued
recognition of the legitimacy and the
authority of the tutor line.
Even her Catholic counselors
readily accepted her at session,
but the situation was far from stable,
far less stable than it had
been under Henry the eighth,
for example.
And that was evident in various ways,
uh,
not only in the risks posed by the
clear internal divisions in matters of
religion about which I talked last time,
but also an international
situation of considerable danger.
England as an ally of Spain
was at war with France,
the city of Cali,
the last English possession on the
French coast had just been lost.
Elizabeth cousin,
Mary,
Queen of Scots.
Then age only 16 was married to the
heir to the French thrown and she had a
claim to the English throne via her
grandmother and radiates sister.
That raised the possibility of a French
ambition of uniting both Scotland and
perhaps England to the French crown.
There was,
at this time a French army in Scotland
supporting Mary's mother who was ruling
Scotland in her daughter's absence.
That posed a potential
threat from the north.
Spain was currently an ally because of
Mary's marriage to Philip the second,
but Spain was also the champion
of research in Catholicism
in Europe and closely
identified with Mary's Catholic
restoration in England.
So what my Phillip,
the second dude with
Elizabeth on the throne.
So the young queen needed advice,
she needed counsel and it's
the relationship between
Elizabeth and those who
sought to counsel her that gives the
early and most decisive part of her reign.
It's distinctive political flavor
as a sister,
Mary had approached death late in 1558
the nucleus of Elizabeth to counsel was
already forming and the central figure
amongst those who advised her was William
sessile later Lord Burley.
Now.
Sessile was a somewhat older man.
He was in his mid thirties.
He is nearly always represented in
television and film productions about
Elizabeth as an old man,
but he was in his mid thirties.
At the beginning of her reign.
He was to serve the queen
for no less than 40 years,
and he forged a very close and
remarkable partnership with her,
which was truly central
to the Elizabethan regime.
Traditionally,
he's portrayed as highly capable
but rather stayed rather dull,
perhaps unimaginative,
congenitally cautious,
a bureaucrat,
but as is increasingly appreciated,
this was far from being the whole man.
Certainly he was a very good servant
of the state and he was a judicious,
deliberative person and a
prodigious really hard worker.
Uh,
he left behind him,
masses of papers,
many of them in his own hand,
which to this day I've
never been fully explored.
He had the habit of working out decisions
which had to be taken by setting up
the pros and the cons on any question
in lists in his personal papers.
As he worked his way through,
he called this reasoning
by question upon a matter,
uncertain.
It was derived from the methods he'd
learned in his classical education,
but he wasn't simply the queen's
cautious plotting advisor.
He also had his own ideas and his own
ideals sessile and some of his closest
colleagues in Elizabeth's first council
where essentially Edwardians by which I
mean they'd cut their political
teeth in the reign of Edward,
the sixth as servants,
junior servants at that time of a regime
that was governed by a privy council in
the absence of an adult male ruler.
So sessile was the queen's man,
but he wasn't just the queen's man.
He had a very strong
sense of public service,
again,
derived in part from his
classical education and he
had a very strong sense of a
state which was independent
of the person of the Monique.
He also explicitly subscribed
to the view that in England,
sovereignty lay not in the crown alone,
but in the crown in parliament.
It was very keen on the notion that the
consent of the whole political nation,
Queen,
Lourdes,
and Commons in parliament
should be obtained for any
major political initiative,
strong sense then of
the state as an entity.
And secondly,
sessile and his colleagues
had an agenda of their own,
which was essentially the reestablishment
and preservation of the Protestant
state.
He wasn't a dogmatist in religion.
He was considerably less advanced
in his religious views towards,
uh,
Protestantism than some of his colleagues.
But nonetheless,
he was a sincere adherent
of the reformation.
Uh,
indeed back in 1552,
some of the meetings about the second
Edwardian prayer book had been conducted
in Settles House.
So the importance of
this ideological element,
this ideological undertone in the
politics of the early reign of Elizabeth
mustn't be underestimated.
Okay.
Then Elizabeth counselors had certain
ideas and certain purposes of their own to
be pursued in a very dangerous situation.
I finally,
they had certain assumptions also about
the new Monique and about the nature of
their relationship to her.
Obviously Elizabeth was a woman,
a young unmarried woman,
and in 1559 shortly after her ex session,
the Scottish reformer,
John Knox,
with quite appalling timing,
issued a book called the first blast
of the trumpet against the Monstrous
Regiment of women.
It was attack upon what he regarded as
the unnatural nature of free female rule,
the regimen of women.
This book was directed
against Elizabeth Sister Mary,
the first of England and
against Mary of Gears,
the mother of Mary,
Queen of Scots,
who was ruling Scotland as regent.
But by the time it came out,
it was deeply embarrassing because it
appeared when Mary had died and Elizabeth
was on the throne.
One of Elizabeth's Bishop's,
John Aylmer quickly was recruited to
answer it and he wrote a book called a
harbor for faithful and true
subjects to defend her rule,
but it was a very odd defense.
He maintained that Elizabeth's rule pose,
no threat since.
To quote him.
First it is not she that rules but
the laws and secondly she make us know
statutes or laws,
but in the honorable court of parliament.
Therefore what makes
you do wherein his peril
in salt.
In short,
what he's saying is that she would not
really rule government would be conducted
in her name and by her royal authority,
but the general assumption was that she
would soon Mary appropriately and in the
meantime the Privy Council would assert
its role in running the country and
parliament would provide safeguards.
It's hard to imagine any of this
being written about a male ruler.
Well,
such expectations showed that Ayla
didn't really know Elizabeth and indeed
perhaps even sessile didn't yet
fully appreciate her potential.
She had had a very long schooling in
caution and in the avoidance of danger,
but she was also in many respects,
very much her father's daughter.
She knew what it was to be a Monique.
She had an imperious temperament and
she was perfectly prepared to assert it
when she was crossed,
nor did she intend to allow
her sex two inhibitor.
In doing that
in 1566 at the age of 33
in to representations made
to her by a parliamentary
delegation over the succession.
She stated though I'd be a woman,
yet I have as good a carriage answerable
to my place as ever my father had.
I am your anointed queen.
I will never be
constrained to do anything.
I thank God I am endued with such
quality that if I were turned out of this
realm in my petticoat,
I were able to live in
any place in Christendom.
She could play the gender
card to her own advantage.
And of course she was to do so many times,
most famously in her speech to her troops,
uh,
Tilbury during the
Spanish armada campaign.
I know I have the body of
a weak and feeble woman,
but I have the heart and stomach
of a king and a King of England.
When the statements like
this where repeatedly to
show she had a great sense of
her own capability and a very strong
sense of her place as Monique and
assertions of this kind where most likely
to come when she felt that her royal
authority was being encroached upon.
She knew of course that
she ruled under the law,
but firstly she had no doubt
of her rights to the crown.
She was a Monique ordained by God
and anointed at her coronation.
Secondly,
she believed that in her person,
the imperial kingship of Henry
the eighth had been restored.
She did not regard her supreme
governorship of the Church of England as
something which had been granted to her
by parliament rather it had been given
to her by God and confirmed
by parliamentary statute.
And thirdly,
she regarded certain matters of state
as she turned them as lying ultimately
within the sphere of
her prerogative power,
her sole power of decision,
the prerogative power,
things to be decided by her and notably
they included the crucial matter of
religion,
foreign policy and the succession
to the throne on these matters.
She would certainly live,
listen to advice and counsel,
but she alone had the last word and she
strongly believed that parliament in
particular had no business
in meddling in such matters
as she told that same parliamentary
delegation in 1566 when they pressured her
on the matter of the succession.
It is a strange thing that the
foot should direct the head in.
So weightier matter.
All of this considered a great deal then
would depend upon how the queen and her
counselors would get along in handling
the central issues of her reign.
And on the whole they
got along pretty well.
On a day to day basis,
the Privy Council ran the affairs of
government under the secretary ship,
first of sessile and then
as a Francis walls income,
Elizabeth would attend counsel frequently,
but on many days they were allowed
to simply proceed with administrative
matters.
Sessile was given a particularly free
hand in his efforts to address the
problems of the Commonwealth
in Economic and social affairs,
uh,
to plan legislation to be brought before
parliament intended to stabilize and
strengthen the nation.
Some of these things
I've touched on already,
but what about those
vital matters of state,
the really central issues as
far as the queen was concerned?
Well,
the first order of business
of course was religion,
the religious settlement.
And as we saw last time
there was essential unanimity
between Elizabeth and her
counselors on that issue in shaping the
religious settlement and in getting it
through parliament does.
The queen's personality was to become
very evident in the way in which,
as I described last time,
she set the limits to the further reform,
which might proceed.
This use of foreign policy and of the
succession were much more fraught.
And here you've got a pattern repeatedly
of pressure being brought upon the
queen and of resistance on her part to
such pressure pressure on her to make
decisions,
which are counselors believed
to be absolutely crucial.
And on her part,
a great unwillingness to take categorical
decisions which might prove to be
irreparable and which might prove
to have unforeseen consequences.
She was very anxious to avoid decisions
which might lead indirections,
which might prove disastrous.
So to look at foreign policy first of all,
early in the rain in April,
1559 the war with France was
ended by the treaty of Katto.
Can Bracey England suffer the
humiliation of losing Cali?
It's last French possession
once and for all,
but that could be blamed
upon Mary and Phillip.
It had happened under Mary's rain and
there was the positive benefit of the
treaty that the peace treaty meant that
the other monarchs recognized Elizabeth
as Queen of England.
That's still left.
However,
the problem of Scotland,
Scotland was still being ruled as a
French protectorate by Mary of geese and
then in 1559 Mary Queen of Scots became
queen of France when her husband Francis
acceded to the French thrown
to sessile.
The best hope of achieving security
in this situation was to encourage
resistance to French domination in
Scotland to encourage in particularly the
resistance of the Scottish lords known
as the lords of the congregation who were
Protestants and who are engaged in
what was at that time still a largely
unsuccessful resistance
to French dominance.
Elizabeth was willing to go
so far as to act covertly.
In the Scottish situation,
even authorizing the smuggling back to
Scotland of the preacher John Knox in
order to stiffen Scottish
Protestant resistance,
but she was exceedingly
reluctant to intervene openly
to help any rebels against
their true Monique.
This time,
however,
sessile managed to persuade her because
of the obvious threat and in 1560 some
English troops and ships was sent
to aid the Scottish covenanters.
They were not very successful militarily,
but in June,
1560 Mary of geese died and in July the
war in Scotland was brought to an end
with the treaty of Edinburgh.
French troops were evacuated from Scotland
and the Protestant Lords took control
in Edinburgh,
so that one a breathing space,
but it was only a short breathing
space because in December,
1560 Francis the second of France,
the young king husband of Mary,
Queen of Scots died leaving
Mary an 18 year old widow.
She returned to Scotland.
She accepted the Protestant settlement,
which had taken place there
though she was herself a Catholic.
But she also made great show soon after
her return to Scotland of the fact that
she maintained a claim
to the English throne,
a claim to the succession.
And this made,
this situation became even worse
in the mid fifties and sixties.
First of all,
when Mary married,
she married Henry Lord Darnley,
who was also descended
from the same tutor,
grandmother as Mary,
Queen of Scots herself by
a second marriage that she
contracted and who also had
a distant claim to the throne.
They married.
And then in 1566,
they had a son,
James,
who was baptized,
a Catholic potential successor
to the English crown.
This time the situation was resolved
not by any English intervention,
but by Mary Queen of Scots
own errors of judgment.
By 1566,
she had fallen out of love
disastrously with Lord Darnley.
Um,
he was a wastrel.
He was a rake.
Uh,
he deeply his exclusion from real power,
uh,
in a jealous rage.
He assisted in the murder of her
Secretary David Richo at one point.
And in 1567,
he was murdered by a group
of Scottish Lords acting.
Uh,
it was said with the covered,
uh,
assistance of Queen Mary
herself with Donnelly dead.
Uh,
Mary embarked upon an adulterous
affair with the Lord James Bothell,
rather romantic figure,
one of the lords of the
Scottish border area,
uh,
with whom she was in love,
and uh,
remained with him until he managed
to obtain a divorce from his wife.
And they married in May 15,
67.
All of this was too much for
the lords of the congregation.
They rebelled.
In June,
1567,
Mary was forced to abdicate and the Earl
of Marie took power as regent for her
infant son James.
Yeah.
Later Mary managed to escape from her
imprisonment in Loch Leven castle,
but having failed to re re to raise
adequate support to restore her to the
throne,
she was forced to flee to England.
She crossed the border and she appealed
to Elizabeth for help in restoring her
to the throne.
This was highly embarrassing situation.
And in this situation,
Elizabeth and her counsel had
to act very circumspectly.
Indeed.
They didn't want to restore Mary Queen
of Scots to the Scottish throne because
the Scottish power in Scotland was now
in the hands of friendly lords of the
congregation who proceeded to bring
up the young James as a protestant.
They couldn't let Mary go to France
either if they allowed that she might in
France reassert her claim to the English
throne as well as the Scottish and
perhaps try to be restored to Scotland
and possibly to England with French
military aid.
Elizabeth offered to hear both sides of
the story and commissioners met to hear
the charges of murder and adultery,
which will aid by the lords
of the congregation against
Mary and to hear Mary's
counter countercharges of treason and
rebellion against her Scottish subjects
and judiciously.
Elizabeth eventually determined that
the case had not been proved either way,
Scotland was neutralized.
It was to remain under the
rule of the Protestant regency,
but Mary could not be released.
Instead,
she was held in what was deemed
honorable imprisonment in a succession of
English castles.
So
that brought a temporary
resolution to England's advantage,
but it also meant that Elizabeth was
saddled as what was described as a
permanent and lively danger in
the person of Mary Queen of Scots.
She was held in custody,
but as you know,
almost from the beginning,
Mary became the focus of plots against
Elizabeth indeed already by 1572 after
the first of these,
some members of parliament,
some members of Elizabeth's council,
including even some of the bishops,
were calling for Mary's head in
order to resolve this danger,
but Elizabeth wouldn't countenance that
she would not execute and anointed clean
when parliament asked her to do so,
she vetoed the bill,
which we've brought before her
with the words Lorenzo visa wrap.
The queen will think about it,
and she did for about 15 years.
She wouldn't execute him anointed queen,
nor would she quietly acceded
and Mary's assassination,
which was also suggested to her
as a way out of the problem.
Some of her counselors simply despaired
and they were vigilant on her behalf,
especially Francis Walsingham,
the head of her intelligence service,
but as yet the queen would not budge.
She also refused to budge
on another vital matter,
the matter of the succession.
And here the tension at the very heart
of the regime is perhaps most clearly
revealed.
Initially,
of course,
people expected that Elizabeth would soon
Mary and that she would bear children,
bear and air.
In 1559 to 61,
various candidates were
being talked about,
Philip the second of Spain,
the former husband of her sister,
Mary offered his hand in marriage,
but that was diplomatically
and politely rejected.
Um,
there was talk of Lord Robert
Dudley as a possible husband,
but there were problems there.
First of all,
he was already married and then in 1560,
when his wife was found dead at the foot
of the staircase in their country home,
there was much suspicion
that Dudley might,
might've had a hand in her
death in order to clear the way.
I think there's little question
that Elizabeth loved Robert Dudley,
but to marry him would have been
an active supreme political folly.
They're considered
Prince Ed Eric of Sweden,
but he was rumored to
be mentally unstable.
They considered the archduke
Charles of Australia,
but he was a Catholic and so it went on.
Nothing had come of all of this by
1562 and nor would Elizabeth name a
successor.
In the meantime,
and then in 1562 she nearly
died of smallpox and the
fragility of the situation
was vividly demonstrated what
would happen if she were to die.
In 1563 when parliament met,
it almost immediately petitioned the
queen to Mary and to name a successor.
Both the House of Lords and the House of
Commons were involved and they were not
very discreet in approaching the queen.
The speaker of the House of Commons using
his privilege of free speech reminded
her of the history of Alexander the Great
and the disastrous consequences of his
failure to provide for a clear succession.
Almost certainly at this point,
the members of parliament were actually
being covered encouraged by William
sessile and the Privy Council who wanted
pressure put upon the queen in this
matter,
but she gave only evasive replies and
parliament eventually gave in and went
into recess without any definite result.
By the time they met again in 1566 the
situation was even worse because of Mary,
Queen of Scots Marriage to Lord
Darnley and her pregnancy and again,
parliament was encouraged to raise
the matter and did so pretty bluntly.
They declared that they would not pass
any taxation bill unless she replied for
their petition of 1563 asking
her to name a successor.
That was why Elizabeth rebuked them in
the words I've already quoted to you for
encroaching on her sovereign rights.
Those he also promised that
he would indeed in good time.
Mary Jean tended to
when parliament pushed again by trying
to incorporate that verbal promise into
one of their money bills.
She rejected it angrily.
She told them they would not have dead,
have treat her to have treated,
have father,
thus nor indeed would day it was right.
But under the pressures of the Times
there had been something of a shift in
political life.
Uh,
Steven Alford says in writing of Williams
successful and the Privy Council,
these were men who were redefining their
relationship with a Monique who refuses
to play by the rules of
monarchy and name her successor.
The role of the council one could say
was shifting somewhat from that of being
merely an advisory and an executive body
to that of attempting to put political
pressure on the queen herself.
And Parliament was taking something
of a novel role in calling openly for
definite policies,
definite courses of action in matters.
The queen regarded as solely her own
prerogative and parliament was to do it
again very soon in 1572 when it called
for the head of Mary Queen of Scots.
So Francis Knowledge,
one of the council told the Queen in 1569,
it is not possible for Your Majesty's,
most faithful counselors
to govern your state well,
unless you will resolutely follow
their opinions in weighty matters.
There was a ring of compulsion in that
reflecting a rather unfamiliar set of
political assumptions about
the relationship between
the queen and her counsel.
As Patrick Collinson has put it.
There were citizens concealed within
subjects in Elizabethan England,
but whatever her,
his views,
the fact remained that
Elizabeth was all they had
and she was secure in that knowledge.
She knew they depended totally upon her
presence on the throne and she stood her
ground putting them off with what
sessile in exasperation described us.
Answers am soulless to their pressures,
answers,
answer lists.
No one can really say when she decided
that she would never marry and perhaps
she never actually consciously
took that decision.
Perhaps matters simply
drifted in that direction.
Eddie decisive action perhaps seemed
unacceptable at particular points in time
and gradually it emerged that
she would indeed never marry.
It's difficult to believe
that she was very serious.
For example,
about the marriage negotiations which
were conducted between 50 and 75 and 50
and 81 with the French Duke of balance on.
She was by that time in her late forties
and it's unlikely that she really took
this seriously,
but if she conserved her freedom of
action by refusing to act on certain
critical matters,
that was also just prolonging what
seemed to many of her counselors to be a
never ending situation of insecurity.
And that was especially the case as
England's relationship with Spain
deteriorated into one of permanent threat,
particularly after 1567 with the Dutch
Protestant revolt against Spanish rule in
the Netherlands and the establishment
as a result of a very powerful Spanish
army.
Just across the narrow cs.
Again,
Elizabeth declined to act decisively.
There were many in her counsel who urged
her to intervene militarily in support
of the Dutch or later as the wars of
religion broke out in France to intervene
on behalf of the French Protestant cause
Robert Dudley now Earl of Leicester was
one of those who pressed her to do so,
so did a Francis Walsingham.
They were frustrated by her willingness
to countenance covert assistance to
these rebels to count
him as an undeclared war.
Spain being pursued by Privet,
like Sir Francis Drake in the
Spanish American possessions,
but remaining unwilling or ways to
openly support any rebels against their
sovereign Monique.
Well,
at this point we can pause briefly just
to consider another dimension of the
shifting structure of political life,
one that you'll already have
discussed or we'll discuss in section.
The way in which under Elizabeth local
government was gradually intensifying and
in increasingly direct relationship was
being built up between the Privy Council
at the center and local justices of the
peace encouraging an extended form of
political participation amongst the
gentry elites of the English counties.
These were men as you know,
who were very conscious of their role as
local representatives of their counties
who pursued that road in
their correspondence with
the center in their petitions
and the questions they raised in their
attempts to modify and influence policy.
And they were men who are
also at the same time,
very conscious of their place in the lab,
the national structures
of government above all,
when they periodically came up to the
center to serve in parliament and indeed
demand for places in parliament,
uh,
was such that the number of members of
parliament was greatly increased under
Elizabeth from 251 in 1547 to 370 by
the end of her reign representation was
being extended.
These things you're discussing section,
but remember that they also represent
a further development of the nature of
political participation
under Elizabeth in the world,
outside Westminster and
in Westminster itself.
When those people came up to take part
in parliament or visited the court.
Well,
all of these various strands of the
situation came together in the mid 1580s.
In 1584,
William,
the silent leader of the
Dutch rebels was assassinated.
Spain looked like winning the war against
the Dutch under the Duke of Palmer,
a brilliant commander.
If that happened,
would England be next
on the Spanish agenda?
This together with the discovery of
the Throckmorton plot against Elizabeth
provoked in 1584 a movement
known as the bond of association,
the circulation and signing of a public
oath by members of the political nation
that they would undertake to revenge any
successful attempt against Elizabeth's
life.
The bond of association was signed by
members of the Privy Council by members of
an ability by the Gentry,
by many clergy,
by mayors of cities,
even in some counties right down to
the level of the leaders of parishes,
Yeoman farmers,
church wardens and so forth.
It had probably been designed by
sessile and so Francis Walsingham,
but it clearly found massive
spontaneous support nationwide
in 1584 they also brought
before parliament and passed
an act for the sec for
the surety of the Queen's
most royal person.
This legislated and obligation upon
the whole nation to take revenge and to
exclude from succession.
Anyone guilty of plotting
Elizabeth's death,
guess who that was aimed at.
Sessile was also secretly drawing up
contingency plans for what would happen if
the queen was assassinated.
He'd actually considered such things as
long before as 1563 but in the mid 1580s
he went into great detail.
If the queen was to
die or be assassinated,
all officers of the crown
were to remain in their posts.
That was a constitutional innovation.
A council of 30 was to be
chosen to govern the nation.
Parliament would then be called
to meet and to choose a successor.
In other words,
he was envisaging a kind of
emergency republic if necessary,
resulting in a parliamentary
choice of king.
It didn't happen,
of course,
but it's still quite extraordinary.
It shows just how far men like sessile.
We're prepared to go if necessary,
in order to secure the Protestant
regime and national independence.
Other factors entered
the situation shortly.
In 1585 Elizabeth was forced at last to
accept the need for direct intervention
in the Netherlands to prevent the victory
of the Spanish army and English troops
was sent under the Earl of Leicester too
stiff and the resistance of the Dutch
in 1586 following the clear implication
of Mary Queen of Scots in the Babington
plot to kill Elizabeth,
which may possibly have
involved entrapment.
Mary Queen of Scots was
at last sentence to death.
There's a bit signed her death warrant,
but then withheld it until the council
acted without her permission by
dispatching the death warrant to
fathering gay castle where Mary Mary was
promptly executed.
When the news came to London,
the queen was furious.
She threatened to have the secretary
of the council executed and she was
probably serious,
but that Boyle had been lanced Mary's son,
James the sixth of Scotland,
now age 20 and beginning
to rule in his own right,
protested against his mother's execution.
But he got over it
knowing full well that being brought
up as a Protestant as he had been,
he was very likely to be the obvious
heir to the English throne in due course.
So the rain had reached its crisis point
and it had been surmounted by forms of
action on the part of central members of
the political nation,
which have led Patrick Cottonson to
describe all this as evidence of a kind of
monarchical republic as he puts it.
Of course,
that term is something of an exaggeration.
It's being rather playful in putting
it forward for the sake of argument,
but it does make a very serious point
about the changing structures of political
life
at about what the expanded increasingly
participating political nation was
capable of conceiving of and even of
doing their capacity to act in defense of
the state that they wanted with
or without the queens consent.
The queen had stood her ground,
she retained the ultimate
power of decision but her
counselors had got what they
wanted to,
the crucial decisions had been made
and who's to say that the delays which
Elizabeth at forced upon them had done
a great deal to help in getting them
right when they were finally made
and so for the moment had rested there.
The last years of the rain,
we're focused upon the war with Spain
and upon a United effort to sustain it,
which was a tremendously debilitating
effort given England's limited resources.
In 1588 the whole nation was mobilized
as a Spanish armada or approached the
English coast and the
defeat of the [inaudible],
the prevention of it's loading troops
from the Netherlands to land in England
and its eventual scattering as it made
its way back to Spain around the northern
coast of Scotland and Ireland.
All of this was regarded as a providential
deliverance of England from this
tremendous threat,
but that providential
deliverance as they saw it,
was followed by a hard slog through
the 50 nineties the durability,
the debilitating costs in treasure and
in men of maintaining an army in the
Netherlands,
the costs of facing rebellion in Ireland
where the Earl of Tyrone rose against
Elizabethan Authority,
aided by Spanish expeditionary force,
which landed in Ireland.
As the war dragged on,
Elizabeth's older counselors
gradually died away.
Lester died in 1588 she wrote on the
last dispatch she'd received from him.
His last letter was it Jim died
in 50 90 sessile died in 1598
the 1590 [inaudible] saw the absolute
pinnacle of the cult of Elizabeth as a
kind of national icon represented
in the great paintings,
the white face,
the great elaborate wig,
the magnificent dressers and so forth.
But also that period saw heads gradually
turning away from the Asian Queen and
towards the assumed.
But as yet formally
undeclared successor James,
the sixth of Scotland called factions,
began forming,
jockeying for position for
when James was to succeed.
And when the Queen finally died
in 1,603 somewhat withdrawn.
Okay.
Set.
And perhaps that her age was over.
James entered joyfully upon the
inheritance for which he had to wait,
waited so long,
but it was to be a rather more complicated
inheritance than James appreciated as
he wrote south from Edinburgh to
become not James the sixth of Scotland,
but James the first of England.
It was an inheritance which contained
many concealed ambiguities about the
nature of the relationship between
the crown and the political nation.
About the way power had come to be
shared and exercised in a kingdom which
remained highly centralized
under the monarchy,
but which also operated a political
system which was heavily consulted,
tentative,
and in many ways participatory
and an inheritance,
which was also ambiguous with regard to
the purposes which the political nation
expected political power to serve.
If the monarchy was to
retain its legitimacy in the,
in the eyes of members
of the political nation.
Before long under the early Stuart's,
some people were beginning to remember
rather ruefully how much better things
had been in the time of Queen Elizabeth
of blessing memory as they tend to,
to put it.
I will not make windows into men's souls.
I will never be
constrained to do anything.
I have the heart and stomach of a king.
I have reigned with your loves.
She had.